jetzt wollen wir zurück in die
hauptstadt gleich werden sie die maz
noch einmal den film noch mal sehen hier
kam es in der nacht zuschüssen und
wieder sollen die clans daran schuld
sein clan schießerei auf offener straße
in berlin um 1 uhr nachts kommt es zum
showdown
ganz in der nähe des berühmten kadewe
augenzeugenberichten die gangster kamen
mit zwei autos dann pfeifen schüsse
durch die straße die alarmierte polizei
umstellten der nähe einen weißen
mercedes amg
nach ersten informationen soll es sich
bei den insassen erneut und mitglieder
eines arabischen clans handeln offenbar
macht die korona krise die kriminellen
noch krimineller
ihr seid die klar ist kein geld mehr aus
lokalen und bordellen ziehen könnt
häufen sich die machtkämpfe in berlins
unterwelt rückblick am abend des ipp
november kommt es zu beängstigenden
szenen vor einem spätkauf in neukölln 30
männer gehen aufeinander los bewaffnet
mit bierbänken shisha pfeifen und
messern auslöser für einen 24 stunden
währenden kleinkrieg zwischen den beiden
lagern
kurz darauf verständigen sich die
kontrahenten mit dem großen
friedensschluss von schöneberg
boxweltmeister mahmood hatte vermittelt
doch drei wochen später lodert die
blutige fehde wieder auf am 27 november
wird in kreuzberg ein 29 jähriger mann
durch schüsse verletzt er muss
notoperiert werden
die täter entkommen unerkannt bei dem
opfer soll es sich laut polizei um ein
mitglied der arabischen großfamilie
handeln der streit am folgenden montag
könnte die fortsetzung der
auseinandersetzung am wochenende gewesen
sein
vor dem club 44 ebenfalls in kreuzberg
gegen die großfamilien erneut mit
baseball-schlägern aufeinander los mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren